what a season it's been here are my top
ten moments so far don't forget to
subscribe to keep getting clips and
thanks for watching
so now you get invited to red carpets
and things yes and literally on red
carpets is this you this is the time the
time 100 was influential people in the
world ever you're one of them how did
this happen
I don't recall that I was yeah they I
was one of the hundred most influential
people even though no one hears heard of
me um and uh I was on the red carpet and
you know when you're doing interviews
and the person sees somebody more
important behind you which is always for
me it's like being at a party and
there's a hotter girl behind you and
they're just like like they'd want you
to drop dead so I saw the reporter do
that and all the reporters are going
crazy in this Kim and Kanye and just
standing there just like owning it just
like being like short and important
and I just couldn't I like think falling
is the funniest thing so I just I just
took a dive in front of them
I'm hearing bad we're
ographers miss the moment when Kanye
broke a smile
no no they did not that did not happen
say there's a follow-up picture where I
loved it like you're struggling for help
in the next one you could have been a
drowning child he was just walking I was
yeah no he did not crack a smile at any
point and then I talked to them after I
saw them and I said to Kim I was like oh
sorry you know when you're like in front
of a celebrity I just become such a
flake I was just saying things I didn't
mean I'm like you and your sister this
is inspiring and like wearing it - good
job the new album Bush and a very sexy
beauty arts course that the by D
Pharrell he co-wrote do you record all
song he produced the whole out for just
the whole album yes sir Wow now is it
true that for Elle he was the one
encouraging you to be a bit more
family-friendly a bit more mainstream
with yeah yeah he made me change certain
words I had a song called so many holes
he made it so many pros well that
certainly toned it down on pros just
prostitutes no they're professionals oh
I see
silly me
the ladies in the video still look quite
like hoes personal they're in a video
and then Pharrell is it true that II
I mean I'm tree enjoyed working with you
but he did have some difficulties
working with you as well yeah when we
were working on a particular song called
California wrong um Stevie Wonder he
came up to the studio and Pharrell had
called a secondhand contact from being
in the studio with me and he kind of
froze he didn't know how to produce
anymore he was stuck it was like might
have to explain what the yes
so at Pharrell was in an environment
created by Snoop Pharrell was no longer
the same Pharrell he was now someone
else
he was not he was not the greatest
producer in the world he wasn't the
greatest because he was just a guy in
the room are you ready okay sure
Cindy Juana Carson oh yeah how about
that one two three four when you hear
the sound of thunder don't you get too
scared
just grab your Thunder buddies and say
these magic words [ __ ] you thunder you
can suck my dick
you can't get me thunder cuz you just
gods for us the Samuel Jackson when you
but would you in college yeah you did
something quite extreme to meet ladies I
wouldn't be a became a cheerleader now
see that's what we now see that seems
quite an out-there thing to do well meet
a woman
well it wasn't necessarily just to meet
a woman it was so I could travel to all
the places that the team I meant to meet
women yeah hi I was going to all these
other schools and hey but did you
pom-poms and stuff I had a megaphone
yeah the girls had pom-poms but I went
to no male school across the street was
an hour woman's school Spellman so we
got our chili to our female cheerleaders
from there so I was the only a
volunteered to be a cheerleader that
year so I taught my roommate into doing
it and you this is awesome we get to
pick all the girls so we picked them and
we got to travel all these other schools
to meet women which was totally dope oh
my god
great Claire
but did you have to do cheerleading to
Jeff to do the chances we did some
cheers but basically we would go I mean
my roommate Navigo hey gang hey gang and
then the girls would do the cheer they
do some flips and we played we weren't
picking them up a whole number that's
it's like a gang yeah basically it you
know and every now and then we do you
know some chairs like you know Edward
Edward he's our man if he can't do it
[ __ ] it
this hand is your hand this hand is my
hand no wait that's your hand
no that's my
oh very good
we don't know who is going to next oh oh
yeah
take that card of me
you
actually talking about it competitors
don't wanna see unites that New York
could you pick a winner the before
bigger winner hmm I mean I'm not saying
anything but we are in a movie so wants
to win yeah when do we yeah okay yeah
she's the best because talking door give
accents this is a weird thing so Chris
Pratt is this this seem so unlikely that
you have now learned to how to do the
voices from town
yeah sort of yeah awesome we love that
garbage TV back in in the States
my wife was crazy about it and when I
was here filming guardians we shot
guardians the galaxy here Annette in
London and and my wife on a came out to
visit and she fell in love with this
show TOWIE The Only Way Is Essex it's
this show that's like basically their
jersey shorts the Jersey Shore from
right from here it's like this town
somewhere Essex I guess and these folks
are just like the worst
it was like I'm a parrot a little bit
and so when I hear when I hear it all
the time I just started picking it up
and started like I could pick up their
accent and do their accent a little bit
numb anomaly I'm okay it's gonna sound
really embarrassing to do in front of a
whole room full of Brits here but I'll
try it anyways so it's like so I want to
say I like a silly sky
honestly like like Michael cheat on me
was in a beef are no cookies tiny sigh
you know you know unless you ever let
miss me one by your mother
okay okay this is gonna be beautiful
you're with the share don't be
discouraged oh I realize it's hard to
take courage
full of people you can lose sight of it
all and s inside you can make you feel
so small but I see your true cares
buddy that's why I love you be a dick
show your true Callas you true who can
Alice
how beautiful
like a rainbow here you are back in :
days for that is now the sword &
Sworcery thing is so a Game of Thrones
is it is the best show in the world and
congratulations on the finale which
rocked out the world
it drove people crazy yes and you must
have read that script with some
trepidation I did yeah I'd ever engaged
yeah and so we're gone yeah Rock gets
robbed Jim you must have been shocked
people know they were going home well
well when they read the scripts
obviously yes about you that yeah
sometimes if you're lucky I think you
get kind of spoken to you beforehand but
no but em but the latest the last death
was definitely there yeah that was that
was a tough one out of nowhere now one
of the people who sadly didn't make it
was of course relate husband Khal Drogo
yeah yes ooh see there's a whiff of
Conan about there we go
well yes there is yeah yes and all the
stuff with him see my dark and brutal
yes but but Bernie the walls some levity
involved he wasn't that was he's a he's
a funny man and just another man he
doesn't know me but it's not me very
funny little bit of whiskey and he's
very funny oh really
but it's burning in the darkest seas in
the darkest scenes yeah so there was
there was there was the the lovely the
lovely and rape scene where I read what
happened kind of early on in season one
and he tried to call it yeah that's
nervous laughter so yeah obviously
there's nudity and you kind of to try
and like lighten the mood you not only
was it a sex scene but it was a kind of
violent sex scene so he decided to for
one of the scenes which was on his back
and my face
he decided to not use a modesty sock but
use a beautiful pink fluffy sock so
getting that close-up from me looking
petrified and just like did I didn't
want it to happen was just lots of
laughter
yeah
any of you explain this tweet was sent
to the show hey I hope you are happy
with yourselves been looking for words
right
this is Thomas so which of you knows
Thomas you what's your name
um I'm Jessica Jessica and why is Thomas
upset with us um Thomas is upset because
I've postponed a date for the second
time so I could come and be here you see
your boyfriend no no we have not been on
a date yes cuz I think so you put him up
why did you put him off for the first
time my sister and this time Kylie's
okay you know that book not that into
you
oh you ain't are you into him I don't
know not that into him Jesus she's come
on what can I suggest you take him out
tomorrow night when this is on
that's right this week's visit to the
red chair that's where we go hello who's
there hello sir hello what's your name
Thomas okay and where are you from I'm
from Durham Durham alright but you live
here now yes okay very good
off you go with this story Thomas uh so
I asked a girl out of couple of weeks
ago and she said yes which was great
because she's quite hot and they're like
a really good
so
tonight I thought I'd come down and see
if she wanted to rearrange for next week
yes I was your very key but she has
given you no indication the cheese here
well I guess he didn't look the good
thing is he didn't make other plans
that's good yeah okay so so this is your
decision now this is you this is you
sending a message to him so Jessica are
we going to flip Thomas you're we gonna
let Thomas war this is okay Kylie please
will you leave him off the red chair
Oh
literally dumped I think never even ones
on a date and he got dumped oh he's
gonna be
we under Graham Norton Show and I have
some quick I'll be back as the LaVista
boys oh yeah
take that card enemy